ううっは寒いよこれぞ来たぞ
アーサーサブこんにちは図3冊です
酒造が東京に得るまで向かってるんですけどもう家を出たのが確か30万くらいかな
夜中の3段くらい逃げずに規定今横浜バーのサービスエリアぐらいまで飛ばしていき
ます
で梗塞脳って言うのはね本当に危ないですあの車のスピードも速いし見せるともう一発
れたと言っちゃうんで人も飛び出した金で非常に危険ね
酵素行塗ってンってまして僕みたいに徹夜でです子供も朝東京に行くんで
危険なのがディ無事分て高速道路とかまっすぐ呈するだけだがすごい眠くなっちゃうん
ですよね僕も件
眠かったです止まってくるときれなかったんですけども居眠り運転が一番危ないってを
僕は
事故っていけない1回もいいねぇ女でしたことないです
ブーブー言っにょ大方チェック
いうか俺の車じゃない6時ぐらいからもう客明るくなってきますね
飲み物も食べ物も実際彼はないで少しでも腹オフくれる病院を減らすために常に彼らは
すかしておきましょう
早速黒いライドオンしますまったく動画とか受けないんですけども
足元が糞ダサいです
シャアまずポイントへいくつかありまして一はぜですねー
1ずっ
ハッハーしついた一夏エアコンを切りますあったかいと眠くなるので一切そういうのも
なしでね6県に誘われてしまうそれがも一緒になしでていきますじゃあ行く座
ガンガン止まった飛ばすちゃダメですよ安全運転で行きましょうねほんとにまずじゃ
ないのよねこれ
いけるかを生かしてくださいね
しばらくは大丈夫なんですよねあせりだした基本的に眠くなることはないので今からで
ございます
e re
me
バーイ
bar ああああ
ああああああ
re good
あっはぁっ
[音楽]
ああああああああ
だーではセグ約座れば牡丹ウアリーグず方は百合の花
だれ妨害ライアム完璧じゃいけんばい
1魔王
[音楽]
ええええええ
やってん
居眠り運転するぞ
[音楽]
me
あっはぁ
まあ寝れば一番安全なんですけども僕みたいにやむを得ず
眠い時にも車に乗らないといけない時があると思います特に高速道路では本当に寝る
ことがもう命取りになるので絶対に寝ちゃいけないと思っています
結構僕が見出せてまずであの女ないんで寝不足の時に高速道路の利用という人はぜひ
試してみてください
不審者扱いされたら
ん
持っています
ごめん